so often we march like robots through
our broken educational system and if we
continue like this we may one day have a
robot as the president United States oh
you don't think it's possible
here's what its campaign would sound
like I am on Jan 1 and I am running for
president of the United States of
America I am the most qualified
candidate because unlike humans
I have no emotions I make decisions
based on pure logic because I have the
most powerful processor in the world I
won't just make America great again
I am great vote for me our Gen 1 the
perfect president you can actually
visualize it can't you see for the
longest time we've been so concerned
about robots taken over the world what
most people don't realize is it's
already happening we've become robots
our educational system is structured to
turn us on to followers you see what
separates us from robots is the fact
that we have the ability to question
things but we stop using that ability
think about it this way how is it that
colleges are selling textbooks for $200
to 18 year old kids when it only costs
$6 to make why is it that tuition costs
as much as it does and why is it that
were pressuring parents to use their
retirement savings to pay for the kids
college education does this making sense
to you this is why I believe this is the
perfect time for us to question our
educational system
before it's too late On January 24
contouring bed David we won't drop out
and get schooled but you'll see how
wonderful will disrupt the entire
educational system
[Music]